Now is also a good time to add
the images for the record and
stop recording button.
Adding images of different sizes
is easy with the next code and
it can make your iOS app
look a whole lot better.
To start,
click on the assets catalog, this blue
icon here in the project navigator.
We're going to add a new image set
by clicking on this plus button
here on the bottom of the screen,
and selecting a new image set.
Let's name this record button
by single clicking on this
newly created image set.
Now we need images for 1x, 2x, and 3x.
We're going to explain, one x,
two x, and three x in full detail
in the UI kit fundamentals
lesson later in this course.
For now, just know that we
need different sizes for
different iPhones and iPads.
Our graphic designers have already
created those icons for us.
So I just need to drag them
over from the finder folder
to the corresponding Xcode box.
Let's drag the record
100 into the one x box.
The record 200 into the two x box.
And then the record 300
into the three x box.
Back in may not storyboard, we can
select a record button in document
outline and under image,
we can select our record button image.
Note that our button now has
both an image and a text.
We can remove the record text since
the image does that work for us.
And attach record label
further explains it.
Select a record field here
under the title and clear it.
And then hit return for
it to take effect.
Now, since the button has changed, our
outer layer constraints are incorrect.
We can fix this issue easily
with the help of Xcode.
Click on the yellow disclosure button
here to see our auto layout issues.
We see three auto layout issues.
One with the Recording Label.
One with the Stop Recording Button.
And one with the Record Button.
Remember that everything on the screen
is positioned off the Record Button.
So we need to fix it first.
Select it here by pressing
the CLO disclosure triangle, and
choose update frames.
Press fix misplacement.
This has adjusted the frame on the
record button so that it fits the image.
For these other two issues we're going
to choose update frames as well.
Let's first fix the recording label.
Update frames and fix misplacement,
and do the same for
the stop recording button.
Update frames and fix misplacement.
Now they're all correct and properly
positioned off of the recording button.
One last thing,
let's turn off the screen background.
Let's go back into the document outlined
here, select a recording button.
Scroll down to the background and
instead of green.
Let's choose the transparent one.
That's it,
our recording button looks much better.
Below you going to find the steps for
adding the icons for
the stop recording button,
so it can look good as well.